Donald Trump is the gift that keeps
giving I said this he's going to be
horrible for the world but in terms of
just like media he is the gift that
keeps giving especially his
disillusioned supporters he has not even
been sworn into office and his
supporters are starting to lose their
minds no one is documenting this better
than a guy I follow on Twitter at free
your mind kid I love the handle black
Aziz Ansari he has been recording and
just pull up an example of what he's a
so he goes and he finds tweets of people
back in November when they were on a
high from Donald Trump and compares
after he makes decisions like you know
putting Goldman Sachs back in charge of
the government and here's a tweet from
Sharon Smith she said on November on
December 2nd she said you make us proud
Donald Trump we enjoyed you thank you
speech we enjoyed you I don't know what
language he's speaking but anyway a few
days later on December 10 she said just
for believing in you in the first place
you could not even wait until you were
sworn in you screwed all of us I mean
this is switch off let's just talk about
mrs. Smith here I mean granted of course
they're gonna be people who are
disillusioned but should we take so much
joy in the fact that this disillusion I
think these people got conned I think
that's pretty evident I mean during the
campaign they would just back him no
matter what said that he would shoot
someone in the middle of Fifth Avenue
and he wouldn't lose any loaders no he's
totally backtracked I mean he's
backtracked so much on prosecuting
Hillary which a lot of people lost their
minds over right we're not going to
prosecute Hillary and they would have
swore he was Lucifer incarnate and then
he backed down on building the wall per
se but then he came back and said okay
we're going to build a wall then he
doubled back down on draining the swamp
he had corey lewandowski go on on the
media and say well we're not really
going to focus on draining the swamp as
much as we are fixing the economy then
he had to come back and say oh no we are
going to drain the swamp it's because
he's trying to have it both ways I think
that's Donald Trump's mo yeah in the
weeks after the election we did a story
about the campaign promises that he
since broken it was something like 12
and that was just a week or two after
the election
point months after you'd have to imagine
that's much higher that just is growing
and growing yeah exactly and and to see
the tears right I mean I try to be the
bigger person uh but you know I'd I am
enjoying seeing this let's go back to
black Aziz Ansari on the second one at
the bottom this is from Frank Frank said
back in November 13th he said great job
president Trump we're 100% in support of
you good luck sir and then like a week
later he says DT Donald Trump you lied
to me about Hillary Clinton you're no
better than the New York Times I
contributed money to you I fell for your
lies shame yeah like I mean it's pretty
obvious this guy had to pay up how many
millions of dollars because he defrauded
students Trump University this guy
that's what he does I mean like okay so
a couple things that like I'm old so I
have these old colloquial that come to
mind like you lay down with dogs you get
fleas right my dad always said like you
can feed an alligator but you can feed
people to the alligator but at the end
of the day you'll be the one the last
one he eats same thing with Donald Trump
you can use donald trump to explore all
of your delusions of grandeur and your
delusions of how you think the political
system should be more is really what i
meant to say you could think donald
trump was going to do that for you
because all the things that he said but
he's a crook he's a he's a Iza he's a
conman and so while you're using his
conman to get your political uh liquid
dreams of course he's gonna turn around
and con you himself you know it's funny
that we're getting this terminology of
con men and phoney from mitt romney who
himself yeah and he actually did the
opposite of what some of these users are
saying guy did position himself to
become Secretary of State he backed off
all of that uh talk and started to suck
up to trump and it didn't work out well
for me got embarrassed on a public stage
yeah yeah so I mean so I have to give
context for me about the word I'm
getting ready to use so NPR just did an
explainer on the word cook right and
they did a full full blown you know
historical background everything
explaining why the alright is now using
his word with regard to people like
Mitt Romney this would be the one of the
few times you'll see me ever agreeing
with alright because Donald Trump
totally cooked the hell out of Mitt
Romney with that dinner party and they
say ah never mind mitt uh we don't want
you Secretary of State and did you see
that picture from that dinner party
where they're landing around eating frog
legs of course because the pretension
wasn't already through the roof at that
point yeah but yeah you see II she
trumped like positioning himself as if
he's the devil and you see Mitt Romney
having to turn around and it's clear
that he's just sucking up to him it
didn't work out well we're Bretton
Romney looked like someone who was on a
date with the oh god I'm getting all
kind of troubles now he's on a date with
a woman he didn't particularly find
attractive and didn't think somebody was
gonna see him in public that I'm a
mother but the tender photos were
deceiving it's pretty shut up
that's how and this is why I say Donald
Trump cooked the hell out of Mitt Romney
and actually he did it to all of America
right let's not just you know misery
loves company mitt all of these
supporters who are now disillusioned
they're just losing their minds because
they realize they elected a con man yes
you elected a con man who has no
interest in helping you in every
interest in helping his bottom line
congratulations Republicans you played
yourself thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the David
Pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated